foreign
to the academy Museum of motion pictures
the largest institution in the United
States devoted to Arts science and the
Artistry of movie making thank you for
coming
the academy Museum of Motion Pictures
acknowledges the tongva people as the
traditional caretakers of the water and
land on which we program curate convene
and discuss we honor and respect tongva
ancestors and the tongva community today
which continue to nurture this land and
water through traditional practice
activism art and education
we also acknowledge their continued work
to safeguard resources
my name is Eduardo Sanchez I'm the
public programs manager here at the
Museum
thank you for joining us in our
wonderful David Geffen theater
today we're going to be experiencing our
documentary shorts nominees panel
presented as part of our Oscars week
programming before we begin the panel
please before we begin the panel public
programming for uh for 2023 Oscars week
is made possible by the Ruderman Family
Foundation which promotes authentic
representation in the entertainment
industry and full inclusion of people
with disabilities throughout all sectors
of society
I would like to thank our ASL
interpreters who will be assisting us
today Richard Loya and ajamu brown
please help me in welcoming to the stage
senior vice president of members
relations Global Outreach and awards
Administration Tom oyer
hello everyone nice to see you all thank
you all for coming as we celebrate our
uh documentary short Film nominees today
I'm here representing Our member
relations and awards Administration team
and as you know we as as we're here to
celebrate the documentary short Film
nominees I feel like I need to tell you
how we got here how did we end up with
our nominees that we have today uh the
way it works is there's a few steps in
the process the first step is the films
need to qualify there's a couple
different ways by which documentary
short films can qualify for Academy
consideration the first step is by doing
a one-week theatrical run to qualify the
second step is by winning a qualifying
Festival award we have a number of
qualifying festivals on our list that uh
films that win those specific jury
awards are automatically eligible to
submit for consideration and the Third
Way is by a film winning a one of the
medals at the Student Academy Awards
throughout those methods uh the films
qualify the next step of the process is
the films need to submit for
consideration uh they submit the pro
submit their film through our process
for the academy and I want to give a
special thank you to Michael Benedict
Lauren McPhee and many others on the
academy team Who oversee the submissions
process and without all the work they do
year-round to get to this point what
this category would not be possible the
next step of course in the process is
the voting so from there with the voting
we work with the members of the
documentary branch of the academy it's
approximately 650 members worldwide that
work as both directors producers editors
Etc that are focused in non-fiction
those members are the ones that view the
films throughout the year as the films
are submitted on our Academy screening
room and at screenings Etc from that
process that each of the members then
vote to determine a short list that
round of voting is in December comes up
with our short list of 15 films from
there then again the members of the
documentary Branch then vote in January
to determine the five nominees that you
have here today the next step of course
is then the entire Academy membership is
are then vote on all 23 categories the
entire Academy membership votes to
determine the winners which ended on
Tuesday so that is done voting is over
we will find out on Sunday what what the
end result will be I want to take a
moment to really thank all the members
of The Academy that we work with year
round and all the viewing
that they participate in it's very much
appreciated and we will continue to
enlist your help all the time
next um next is my pleasure is to
introduce you
three wonderful members of the
documentary Community who I have the
pleasure of working with all year round
not just during Oscar season uh these
are the three documentary Branch
Governors Kate amend Chris heginess and
Gene Chen
good afternoon I just want to thank Tom
oryer for every day he worked so hard
for a documentary branch and also
Michael Benedict without you guys we
don't know what to do it is my honor to
introduce our newest Governor Chris
hijides and
this year makes three editors for the
documentary Branch Governors Chris
thank you Gene
um welcome everyone I'm just so happy to
be here I'm probably the oldest
filmmaker in the branch but the youngest
of newest governor and it's my pleasure
to serve this institution and I love
being with my fellow Governors Madame
Governors here and
um they've taught me so much already
especially Kate who after nine years is
going to be leaving us and we're very
sad about that but thank you Kate for
all your guidance
thank you Chris and Gene and Tom and
Michael
and this is such a wonderful
day week for all the filmmakers you know
as a as an editor
I have worked on short films and I think
this the short film is a very unique and
distinct art form
and in some ways I think it's more
challenging sometimes to tell a concise
impactful story in a short time frame
and
the people you're going to be hearing
from today have all done extraordinary
work I think their films are magnificent
they're powerful
resonant
I've seen them
many times there there's such beautiful
films and I assume you were here
watching them or you have seen them
but these are a true artists that are
you're going to be hearing from today so
with that let me introduce our wonderful
Museum exhibitions curator Jenny he who
will be today's moderator
thank you so much Kate Jean and Chris
it's really lovely to be here today
hello and welcome to Oscar week at the
Academy Museum of Motion Pictures and
welcome to the documentary short Film
nominees panel
this is the first year that we are
presenting Oscar week here at the Museum
and we're super excited what a perfect
venue to celebrate everything Oscars and
all of our nominees who are here with us
today
I'm Jenny heat exhibitions curator here
at the Museum and specifically curator
for many of our galleries in our core
exhibition storage the cinema if you
haven't done so already I encourage you
to visit our Galleries and exhibitions
and especially our impact reflection
gallery on the second floor which
highlights film's capacity to shape
public awareness and to create social
change fittingly many of the films that
are featured in Impact reflection are
documentary features and shorts and for
their support
of the Museum's exhibitions programs
numerous other initiatives and in
particular for helping to orchestrate
Oscar week here at the Museum I would
like to first thank Academy president
Janet yang
the academy CEO Bill Kramer the academy
Museum's president and director
Jacqueline Stewart
our chief audience officer Amy Houma
and I would also love to thank Eduardo
Sanchez silver Feldman and Tom oyer
thank you all for your tireless efforts
and dedication
in making this incredible week of
celebrations happen we are so thrilled
to have all of our Academy Award
nominees here and we're so thrilled to
celebrate them here at Oscar week at the
Museum before I invite our nominees on
stage I would like to ask our ASL
interpreter to please take their seat
and now please allow me to introduce our
nominees for best documentary short film
for stranger at the gate Joshua seftel
and Connell Jones
further Martha Mitchell effect and Alvar
gay and Beth levison
[Applause]
for how do you measure a year Jay
rosenblatt
[Applause]
for a haul out afghania or bugava and
Maxim arbigayev
and for the elephant Whispers cartagi
Gonzalez and gunit manga
[Applause]
well thank you everyone for being here
with us today this is so exciting I
can't wait to jump in and talk about
your films so first I think uh for just
a question I would love to pose to the
group
um and this is for everyone this is a
really an opening question about how did
you come upon or discover the subject of
your films really you know in other
words what inspired the idea for your
respective movies
so I would invite to start off
um with a stranger at the gate
so thank you everybody for being here
it's very exciting to be here at the
Academy Museum
and I'll say that we we started we found
this story in a in a newspaper article
and we thought oh my God how can this be
real and we went and we reported on it
and we found the people and we were just
blown away by this idea that this
kind of crazy guy who was mixed up and
wanted to become was almost a domestic
terrorist was able to change
and we were so inspired by that because
of the times we live in right now and we
just felt like we need stories like this
uh right now and so we leaned into it
and we went to Muncie
and got to film with Bibi and Sauber and
and they took care of us and cooked for
our crew and
made sure we were had a great time in
Muncie and it was an amazing experience
to get to know those people
and every time I
documentary films I think the first
question for me is always
yes exactly how did you come upon this
idea and Jay later on I'm sure your your
answer will be very specific
um but Ann and Beth I love to hear about
the Martha Mitchell effect and really
what inspired you to tell the story now
yeah so
um my co-director and I Deborah
mcclutchy
um came up with the idea together we um
it wasn't that novel an idea originally
it was we had heard it um I heard about
Martha from a slow burn podcast
um the first episode and we couldn't
believe that we neither of us had heard
of her
um she'd been completely glossed over in
history
um we only knew about All the
President's Men
um and the more that we dug into you
know the archive just online we realized
that she was this kind of amazing
intelligent charismatic character and
was really sort of a Pioneer and that
the reason we hadn't heard about her was
because there had been a systematic
gaslighting campaign against her
um sort of catalyzed by the Nixon
Administration and we realized that was
sort of the larger story and the more
that we dug into the White House tapes
the more we found evidence of that and
you know the parallels were sort of
uncanny with what was going on
um today and it's sort of like the gift
that keeps on giving
um with January 6 and the you know
multiple impeachments so
um we just wanted to highlight and sort
of exhume this this um heroine this
complicated heroine for today's audience
someone who was brave enough to cross
party lines and speak truth to power
yes and fascinating that the Martha
Mitchell effect is an actual term and
and really bringing that story to the
Forefront them thank you and and Jay
this is well I suppose what inspired you
to
um make this film I I won't ask you how
did you come upon the subject of your
film
um yeah there was no accident in coming
upon the subject
this is about our daughter and uh
actually we celebrated her birthday
yesterday oh
wow and you know this film is all about
birthdays her birthdays so she's 22 now
and um
you know when she was born uh it was
parenting was obviously the priority but
also I've been a filmmaker for a long
time and
I figured how how can I do both so I
made this film when she was born till
maybe 16 months old called I used to be
a filmmaker and that was the beginning
of making films with her and we made
four films
until she was age five then I stopped
because she was really developing a
personality and I didn't want it to
influence her her privacy or
change her in a way
but we continued with this other idea
which is how do you measure a year which
became how do you measure a year where I
would film her from Age Two until 18. on
her birthday
asking her similar questions some same
sometimes adding something
and um
but I didn't know I was necessarily
making a film that would be released I
just knew that at the very least we'd
have this footage for her to have you
know a record
and when covet hit I looked at the
footage and I thought yeah I think
there's a film here so I hadn't looked
at the footage at all from year to year
and uh then the you know the rest is
Oscar history
thank you so much Jay and afghania and
Maxim I would love to hear about how you
came upon the story for haul out yeah we
were working well first of all we are
from the same region um from yukota
We're from Eastern Siberia and
um we were following
um a community of indigenous chukchi
people who are still living off the land
and the Sea and for a couple of years
and we didn't know actually about all
out
um uh strangely even though it's like
the biggest Gathering of walruses on the
planet which is which was just 15
kilometers from the village where we
were and when Hunters brought us their
first time and it was empty we did and
they just said that there is thousands
of walruses holding out here every year
and in this little Hut there is this
lonely scientist living and studying
them and we just thought that this
couldn't be true like it didn't seem
like it could possibly be and next year
we came back and we saw it and we were
completely overwhelmed by by what we saw
and we came back to make a film yeah
yeah and just want to add that we spent
a whole season with the scientists and
at least and it took us three and a half
months so we stay on the field for that
time
uh observing his work and the whole out
certainly not least
we love to hear about how you came upon
the subject of your film
this is actually in a place that I call
home and I was driving one day from Ooty
to Bangalore in the south of India to
pack my things and shift back home and
that's when I saw this little elephant
cuff that was just three months old
walking on the side of this road with
this with this man called woman and I
leaned out of the car and I shouldn't
have been doing that but I was so happy
to see such young calf and so excited so
and after that woman sort of he back
into me so I pulled my car over to the
left and jumped out and I went and
joined them we went on to the river and
Raghu ran in full speed into the water
started splashing around throwing his
trunk in all directions and at that
point it just really struck me that you
had this unusual bond between between
this tiny little calf who's a wild
animal and with this human being so that
made me to sort of explode deeper into
the background of the subject and that's
when I realized that the Asian elephants
are endangered and they're only about 35
000 to 40 000 of them left and that made
me really want to
to portray this beautiful family bond
that I was experiencing and I wanted to
Showcase to the world that that there's
all this there's all this love and I
wanted to help protect the elephants and
also help that translate to other
species across the world and that's how
the story came into being
thank you yeah
and I would love to dive thank you
everyone for for that answer those
answers and I love to dive deeper into
each of your films for the elf and
Whispers it's a movie about two
caretakers and an orphaned elephant as
you just mentioned and talking about
that bond between animal and human while
you were making this film we certainly
can see it on screen but were there any
moments that surprised you just to see
this close Bond and and how Ragu and
bamin and belly interacted together
the entire thing was just really special
I think when you're out in the middle of
the Wilderness just filming out in the
middle of the forest that itself is very
special and there's nothing that you can
sort of preempt before
so every moment was surprising and just
living with the elephants and and
experiencing the special bond and
watching the entire ecosystem happen in
front of your eyes so yeah
I think
definitely
um
over the year I mean I uh and then
karthikey puts it you know like when
belly does ask Amo to lay down and she
does and it's almost like a surprise so
there were many moments like that where
the elephants reacted and you know have
reciprocated love like like human babies
so it's been a I think a lot of of
worthy moments for even the crew and and
we hope we were able to capture and
translate some of those
and it's also a love story The Elephant
Whispers And at what point did you
decide to add that element or was that
always part of your plan in the
beginning to tell this love story
between the two caretakers
it actually sort of unraveled as the
documentary was happening because you
would see all these cute moments of them
together and and Bowman and and belly
have actually been living together for
many years before this and it was just
really special thing that unfolded over
time
yeah oh that's great yeah I was
wondering that I was as I was watching
the film thank you so much
um and to move to a haul out
so in your story we follow a Solitary
Man in Siberia in the remote region and
you mentioned of course that this area
is familiar to you can you talk a little
bit more about this area and what it was
like to actually film there
it's a very special place actually that
beach where walruses hold out it's also
been a former settlement of of chukchi
people
um a century ago so we we still were
finding this artifacts from from
um from from that time of like arrows
made of walrus tusks and tools Etc it
was really special and you kind of feel
this atmosphere that you know quite
spiritually charged and we try to to
show it in the film
um a bit like you know give space to the
elements to the sea to the roughness of
of of landscape it is a very
um rough place and but for us because
we're from from the most northern place
you can possibly be probably like you
look on the map and it's like on the
edge of of the world literally
um but there's so much Beauty in this
landscape it's so subtle and so
atmospheric and we were just really
trying to
to capture that and of course there were
some challenges technical challenges
like you know there was no electricity
of course and we had to you know figure
out how to charge the batteries how to
get water and get you know deliver the
food with us Etc but it was all
um you know we were following the
scientists who's been doing it for years
for 10 years so
Beautiful film and and I loved how it's
a broad region but you were also able to
capture the intimacy too of the
scientists living in in that region and
of course the film talks about or you
know touches upon the ongoing impact of
climate change
and it's Illustrated in this movie and
documented film Can Be an Effective tool
for activism how do you see that fitting
into your practice specifically with
this movie the use of filmmaking for
activism
there are so many
um there are so many ways we can tell
stories of climate change and and
um we are just doing our bit from our
part of the world from our home home
region and of course our story is quite
heavy and sad but I think you know it
just shows the reality and I think we
need to know what is actually happening
in the region and
um
we since the film is uh came out we were
just amazed by the amount of support
that the scientists received also and
now he is because of the film he is now
able to continue his research and um and
found support for the programs that he
he'd been developing and dreaming about
for years so that I think for us that
was the most important part of it all
just to see the power of
of the film and how actually you can see
the tangible difference
that impact scientists life of course
when we talk about animals and when we
talk about ecosystems unfortunately this
this process is irreversible and we need
to understand that and we need to
understand that we need to act to so
that it doesn't get worse and we need to
understand that it's all connected this
animal's a migratory species you know
one day they're in Siberia the other
season there in Alaska it's all
connected there's no borders for animals
and we need to all come together as
human beings not just separate
nationalities or separate countries
yeah and one of our goal was
um just do a kind of pure observation
and
and then kind of let the audience decide
and thinking about the climate change
about the what's happening now in the
art degree Arctic regions
yes
it's such a powerful message and and of
course film is powerful in so many ways
narrative films certainly but
documentary films have such a special
place in terms of grounding A Story in
real life and that
um impact whether it's Global or you
know a story that is very local
um it's amazing to see the range of
stories here on stage with us today and
thank you so much evgenia and Maxim for
for talking about your film and I love
to move to uh how do you measure a year
Jay
speaking of intimacy um so you mentioned
you interviewed Ella every year on her
birthday from Age Two to age 18 and I've
read that of course you didn't watch the
footage until the the last interview so
that would be accurate to say right well
until two years after the last interview
until she was 20. wow and if you could
go back it was is there a question
having seen the footage that you wanted
to ask Ella that you didn't
yeah you know um
in the film I actually say that I wasn't
I think it was age 17 maybe 18 I said I
actually wasn't thrilled with my
questions when I reviewed everything I
thought I could have done better
um I'm not sure it mattered because I
think the film is more
less about the answers to the specific
questions and more about how she
answers them you know and how she grows
and how we see her
in 29 minutes go from a two-year-old to
a young woman
but that said
um I was thinking I wish I had asked her
something like uh
what what is God I wish I asked her that
question because I would have been
interested to see how she processed that
through the years
and get to maybe a more spiritual answer
maybe
um
but you know since the start of when she
was two I had to the questions had to be
at least understandable so that might
have been way too soon for for a
two-year-old
but
maybe I could have added that question
in as the years went on but I kind of
just got into a rhythm and I did add a
few questions like I asked her how
how what does she want to say to her 25
year old self and that was a hard
concept for her at first but she starts
answering that more coherently as the
film progresses
it's a as a concept of course it's
so great to see as you mentioned the
evolution of the questions and and how
as a person grows you know their answers
change and that power question did
really really sticks to me and just
understanding of course the there
there's a moment where I suppose it was
misinterpreted but yes
um
but just thinking about how a
two-year-old would answer that question
versus of course an 18 year old and you
touched upon this in your answer to the
first question Jay but thinking about
parenting your your job as a parent and
your job as a filmmaker and on this
movie
were there moments where these two
different opposing roles didn't line up
for you as a parent and as a filmmaker
um I think they kind of lined up uh in
most cases
um there were some surprise moments that
as a filmmaker
I was very interested as a parent I was
very surprised like
I asked her
um what are you afraid of I think it was
eight six or seven and she says you
and has a filmmaker I thought well
that's interesting as a parent I said oh
really
so I didn't totally line up there
um
and then the power question that you
brought up
um
I didn't realize that it was a
misinterpretation until I was editing
the film
so in fact her answer to that question
when she was three is probably the only
thing that stayed with me in all the
filming and I thought I for years I was
thinking why did she say that
and then when I was editing it it just
you know and and
looking at the spelling of the word it
just clicked
yeah it was certainly a very precocious
answer if not
I'm assuming people have seen the film
so
thank you so much Jay of course so Ann
and Beth for the Martha Mitchell effect
um you've already mentioned of course
Martha Mitchell is a significant figure
she was the wife of um Attorney General
John Mitchell under Richard Nixon
and you know there's so much
um
you know speaking to the relevance of
this topic we're talking about
representation of women in the media
we're talking about you know A Woman's
quote-unquote Place in 1970s America and
I would love to hear a little bit about
how these two structures in your view
factor into the depiction of Martha as a
Villain at the time
oh
um
well I think Martha was certainly a
threat to the Nixon Administration
um
early on I think they appreciated her
she kind of brought attention in a
positive way to the administration and
she was bright and she was funny and she
was quick but then she really became
extremely inconvenient when she started
to know what was going on
so I think that we were really
interested in looking at that power
Dynamic the administration this male
Administration vis-a-vis Martha and we
were definitely interested in looking at
the role of the press and how they
shaped The public's view of Martha and
um you know the administration certainly
used the press to their advantage as
much as they could and she was also very
good with the press as well so I think
we were interested in that relationship
between an individual and power and the
Press so there there that was one
triangle and I think that Anne might
speak to another
yeah I mean I think when we um we knew
that we could tell Martha's story that
it was very rich in those six years
um with the play-by-play but the real
heart of the film is the love triangle
that sort of emerged with um between
Martha and Nixon sort of vying for the
attention of John Mitchell and in a lot
of ways it was also you know sort of a
dissolution of a marriage you know it
was very important for us to start with
like what are what's the Fallout or the
externalities of a political Scandal
because they were very much in love when
they first entered Washington and then
by the end they weren't theoretically
um and you know eventually John Mitchell
chose his boss over his wife
and when I think about this film it's I
love listening to what everybody has to
say about their films and how personal
they are for at least to the point that
we've gotten to this far and I think in
many ways Martha is the Martha Mitchell
effect is a historical film but
um it's also very personal for us sort
of the personal is the political and I
think we all felt really
um
uh like it was a form of almost activism
for us to make this film so you know I
just want to acknowledge that we had an
all-female team
um I think they're over there Deb the
co-director Judah producing partner
so
yeah just wanted to look at it through
our female lens as well
yeah and
um speaking of love between John
Mitchell and Martha Mitchell it was it
was really interesting to see that
footage of John Mitchell actually
talking about
Martha later on you know towards the end
of the film
and it's the you use of course archival
footage
um primarily in in the film The Martha
Mitchell effect while between
conceptualization of the film and as
you're digging through the research and
looking at this footage were there any
moments where you pivoted because of of
um reviewing the archival footage
pivoted in the storyline yes
that's a great question
I mean nothing that comes to mind
um I mean there were certainly moments
where you know we would come upon
archival and we're like this is
astounding like we have to devote as
much time as we can to it like there's
this moment where she comes downstairs
outside of her New York City apartment
and gives a sort of impromptu oppressor
and it's it's all verite it's
unbelievable and I think when we first
we didn't know about it and when we
first saw it it sort of I don't know if
it really pivoted the storyline but we
certainly gave a lot of attention to it
and it was it was certainly like um
uh it's it was a point where she was
afraid that she was going to be killed
and she was really leaning on the press
and she said to the Press look I lean on
you you know I depend upon you the
Pressed
um for my for my safety there was also
another point where um there was an
interview
um where she talks about before
California and after California and we
realized in the way that she was framing
it that that was really a Rubicon for
her that that's how she saw what
happened to her and we sort of start the
film you know in the in the what what is
the the future right 70 74 sort of
looking back at what happened to her
trying to kind of untangle you know what
what happened I you know I went to
Washington this way and this is what
happened to me
um and you know it was sort of trying to
untangle also the effect of gaslighting
on her you know someone who is you know
um you know a higher power which is
essentially questioning her lived
experience so
those were two examples
thank you so much
um and going from a you know a
documentary with a lot of historical
footage archival footage to stranger at
the gate which really told the story
through interviews primarily and I would
love to hear about that why did you
choose this method of hearing directly
from from Mac
um from Mac's wife daughter from the
congregants of the Islamic Center
thank you
well yeah so that we we didn't have any
footage
uh so you know we're retelling a story
that was not documented and we had to
figure out how do we do that so we knew
that we had these amazing compelling
subjects
and we set up the interviews we did them
all in the same room which was the
basement of the Islamic Center of Muncie
and we did that partly because we didn't
have enough money to
we could shoot all the interviews
quickly in one place and move people in
and out and the budget allowed for that
amount of time so we um we shot it that
down there and we we had multiple
cameras because we knew that we were
going to rely on these interviews to
help tell the story and
we um we also we Connell and I both wore
microphones when we did the interviews
because we wanted not just their answers
but sometimes our questions and then
even sometimes the space in between the
question and the answer because we we
were looking for moments that would
reveal our characters reveal truth about
the story and we um so we really leaned
into that interaction and those
interactive moments
and there's a few spots in the film
where we we kept that because we felt
like sometimes that the question and the
the non-answer was more interesting than
any words that the subject might say
like mac we ask him one question the
first question we ask him
and he doesn't even answer it
but it's this I love that moment because
I feel like you learned a lot about him
so um the interviews where we we relied
very heavily on them but we also
relied on um aerial shots
those were the probably the two primary
pieces that we use for visuals and the
thought behind that was
a few things one was um
this idea of surveillance
sort of a military surveillance feel
because that's what the story is about
we also were really interested in this
idea of the eye of God
and um
and then the other thing about Aerials
was we didn't want to have any
reenactments in the film we wanted
people to be able to imagine what
happened instead of seeing what we
imagined happened and and so
the Aerials sort of allowed for
that space for the viewer to imagine
what happened so you you're looking down
and you you're like okay it's happening
down there I can't quite see what's
happening but I can imagine it and in
some ways almost like when you're
listening to the radio and you picture
the visuals we wanted that feeling in a
cinematic way and and so those were the
building blocks of of the film visually
for us
thank you so much for expanding on that
all that so to talk talking about the
interviews because in a lot of
documentary films there are talking head
interviews but it's not about relaying
information or or even just relate you
know telling that story but the moments
just capturing those interviews and
seeing the subjects talk about their
story is make is what really makes
documentary films so powerful and thank
you so much for expanding on that so
eloquently
um and so for stranger the gate this is
a story as you mentioned that takes
place in Muncie Indiana
um about a former Marine who served in
Iraq and Afghanistan and the community
of a local mosque and what happened when
the two came together
um it's a very powerful story about
spreading peace about not making
assumptions and certainly about
islamophobia very very intricate complex
subjects and really coming out of film
filming the story and and hearing the
story first hand were there any moments
where you thought this could be expanded
upon or used as a teaching tool or
anything outside of the the story itself
that you were trying to tell
the film as a tool yeah
um yeah we've been uh approach to use
the film as a teaching tool by uh Facing
History and they have they're connected
to 140 teachers across the US and so
thousand sorry 140 000.
um and uh yeah so we're speaking with
them and uh gonna get the film out
through the that curriculum
um and then other organizations too uh
we've been talking to Veterans groups
and stuff like that so yeah
yeah I'll just add to that that we this
film was part of a a set of films that
we've been making for the last uh eight
years and uh the set of films is called
The Secret Life of Muslims and the the
uh concept was to tell stories about
American Muslims that
shatter stereotypes and build Bridges
and
uh so this film is the 25th film that
we've made on this subject matter
so the in the intention was from the
beginning was
uh purposeful to try to change hearts
and Minds
and um and so that and that came out
about because
when I was growing up as a boy in
Upstate New York I faced a lot of
anti-semitism
and when I became a filmmaker then 911
happened and I saw my friends who were
Muslim facing similar kind of hate and
that's when we decided we wanted to do
this here this series of films
for telling the story of stranger at the
gate and and really congratulations and
thank you to everyone for the powerful
essential important captivating
Beautiful Stories represented by all the
filmmakers up here today
um so I I want to you know throw another
general question out to the group and
I'd love to start with the elephant
Whisperers you know what advice do you
have regarding the creation of
narratives around marginalized
communities
if any
of narratives at all
sure so I think
there was a very conscious decision
that while we were filming this that the
team took
um was to not like have a voice over to
let the community to have woman and
belly talk for themselves represent
themselves you know a lot of people ask
us how can we help what do they need
they actually don't need money you know
they're self-sufficient they and they
are also giving a message of
self-sufficiency through the film uh in
fact it's really important for us to
learn from them that they take whatever
they need from the village from the from
the jungle but and that is enough for
them you know so I think we there's so
much deeper knowledge there is so much
history
um in fact we have so much to learn from
them than uh the other way around so
we're happy to uh to to be allowed to
enter their work world and to be able to
tell their story in its truest form I
think that was our attempt to be fly on
the wall and observe them but rather
than to lean in or impose anything or
you know try and maybe get our ideas of
com you know cities and how uh how we
are and how our mindset is so in fact we
ended up learning a lot from them so
while telling stories of marginalized
Community I think
allow them to speak for themselves
I think when it comes to indigenous
people they very rarely had a voice and
I think that was one thing that really
wanted to focus on
and here we have Bowman and belly who
who come from the cartoon icon community
and they're only 1700 of them left and I
think that was one of the things and I
think when we look at coexistence on
this planet we really have to go back to
how indigenous communities have
coexisted alongside with animals and
there's so much that we can learn from
them I think with neutral respect and
cooperation can we help save the planet
and I think we really need to go back
and learn so much of the ancient
knowledge instead of proceeding ahead
with a lot of Technology go back to the
basics look at how we Thrive and how we
share our space and what we're doing to
other uh other beings on the planet
[Applause]
great thank you
um and evgenia and Maxim and this is a
question of course that doesn't have to
be specific to your films but thinking
about being a documentary filmmaker and
just that in general creating narratives
around marginalized communities if you
have any thoughts about that
um yeah I mean we're besides this film a
haul out we are also
um as a photographer I'm also a
photographer I've been doing a lot of
Stories on indigenous communities in
Siberia and in general in circumpola
work or world in the Arctic I worked for
more than a decade and always following
doing a long observation following
communities for a long time I think the
main thing
um for me was to is to well first of all
I also cover our own Community which is
you know native community of Siberia and
and
I think that as filmmakers as creatives
of what is important for us is to not
only tell the story but
um try to translate the feel that people
have towards the natural world and the
pace and just the the way of being with
animals and I think the cinema is such a
powerful language we can actually do it
and without narration without kind of
maybe well you know in in our case
without being you know planting like of
certain seeds of thoughts but just
letting you
see the place of these communities as it
is but try to
um with artistic tools really translate
that love and that connection and
through the sound through the uh
photographs through uh through moving
image I think that for for us as
filmmakers that's the biggest challenge
and that's the biggest excitement
actually that we can do that and the
more stories that will come out
um from this community's representatives
of this communities that can channel
that that other way of being that other
way of seeing uh the other
um way of relating
um I think that would be our world would
become richer
thank you and uh Jay Joshua Connell and
Beth if you would like to
add to any of that just the idea or the
question of creating narratives around
marginalized communities
oh so sorry for us I'm sorry
I mean I just I for me as a producer
I've really committed so much of my work
to telling stories about women by women
I feel that those stories are so
important and have been overlooked for a
long time
um there's so many chapters in our
Collective history that are told through
a male lens or we know the the male
experience but we don't know women's
experience so
um I think it's really important that we
tell all of these stories our world is
really rich there are many experiences
many point of many points of view
so I just applaud all of this
storytelling and and yeah and for me I'm
I'm more invested in telling stories
about women
um yeah I mean history is written by The
Victors right and it's these there's so
many stories that are lost in the
crevices I mean it was really important
for us to
um you know sort of prioritize Martha's
voice because her um her story had been
lost to history so we wanted to restore
her agency let her tell her story as
much as possible
um so that really dictated our form
um and I feel like there's so many other
stories that are that are that are
hidden and um
you know I I I'm excited for people to
look back at history and and and really
pull out these stories not just women
but people of color and um and like
let's let's look back and see what there
is to say
thank you so much for contributing to
that conversation
um I we have time for one more question
so and this is a general fun question
let's start with Joshua and Connell
um what are the documentaries films uh
art other cultural materials have
inspired your own work
um my all-time favorite film is American
movie uh which is a verite film uh about
filmmaking uh and it's just so endearing
and so intimate and so funny
um I recommend anybody watch it I think
it's only available on DVD now but um
it's by Chris Smith and uh I love it and
it's it it plays a really fine balance
and
showing someone's life intimately and
being able to laugh at it and love what
they're going through at the same time
so there I love that one
I never knew that because that's one of
my favorite films no wonder we work so
well together
um I really I think that these films are
really remarkable and they're all so
different but um I I really I'm so blown
away by this selection in this group of
of people and what they've created and
so
I enjoyed watching this program that I
think you all just watched and uh
proud to be a part of it
and like we're screening the short films
again after this panel as well so for
anyone who didn't have a chance to catch
it beforehand
um please catch it now
but Ann and Beth I would love to hear
about what other films art cultural
materials really broad question have
inspired your own work
sure I mean I think we thought a lot
about Senna when we were making this and
inspired by that that it's an
all-archival film it's led by voice over
and and it really you really get into
the head of the protagonist
um so I I personally was very inspired
by that I'm also going to say I've been
very inspired by Jay rosenblatt's films
I love all of his films
um it's all archival films so you've
been an idol and inspiration for me
thank you
uh it's funny this was I hadn't made an
archival film in a long time or worked
on one uh my heart has always sort of
been with verite films so what comes to
mind when we were Kings
films by the maisels
by D.A pennebaker and Chris hegedith so
anyway hmm
so uh anyway just uh you know what's so
great as you when you get to work on a
project and then you try to understand
the world of that project and you watch
all kinds of things and you read and you
watch you consume media you listen to
different music so
um
I think the verite films have really
inspired my career but this project I
went to a lot of different
places to find inspiration to support
the directorial team
thank you Jay
yeah
um
well you know I make different types of
films but one thing that I do a lot is
make personal documentaries this one
being no exception
so in that realm the films of Alan
Berliner Ross mcelwee are very
influential uh
for this particular film also a
longitudinal films like Michael aptit's
7Up series
um you know it is something that
everyone goes back to when they say
something that happens over time
unfortunately I would love to have had
him in the audience but he passed away a
couple years ago
um yeah so I think mainly those come to
mind for that question
great thank you
for for me
when working in the Arctic it was always
very inspirational to read accounts of
first explorers and and
um but the people who are coming to
explore and people who were there
already meeting the explorers and just
to understand what it feels like to be
in such isolation and so that was always
inspirational I think I've read all the
accounts of all the explorers and mostly
male of course but then there is also
women and and and it's very different
also views on on exploration and
Solitude and in terms of films and not
documentary but if
in terms of Aesthetics and just the art
of cinematography of course it's uh the
great Russian director tarkovsky which
has been always an inspiration for me
well for me uh the biggest inspiration
come from our parents and from
especially from our father because you
know when we were kids he always took us
to the
um like Wildlife Journeys and
I remember this that how he he gave us
love to the nature and that's inspiring
us
but as a cinematographer really
inspiring of
all polish documentary films these
compositions and the beauty of one that
you see each shot as a as a photo it's a
photography
well I think for me a documentaries like
Sea Of Shadows viranga Blackfish all
basically showed how
how animals are
suffering and I think that really
inspired me to go after something that
was that showed all the love and
connection because I think we as humans
are really making it very hard for
animals to thrive on this planet and
and I think that's what really inspired
me to go ahead and move on to something
to show the love and connection uh that
we share with this planet and other
living creatures
I come I come from fiction world I have
produced a bunch of uh films from India
that have traveled given us a lot of
love and
um
in the documentary world I have just
absolutely loved Amy uh I and the whole
Spectrum I love Act of Killing I mean I
think there is a rebel inside me which
is so in awe of that I know this is very
different from what we have been on a
journey on but I want to say that the
world of documentaries is uh recent and
is newer in India I'm very inspired by
the work of our executive producer and
co-editor Doug blush uh and you know
been being like a mentor and through his
eyes also learning I have learned a lot
on this journey
but my inspiration to go behind this
story was my director karthiki and her
passion and her debut film that I wanted
to make sure that I can provide a space
for her to be able to do this in the
purest form
thank you so much thank you everyone for
sharing it's um it's great to not only
hear about the range of experiences and
and the range of different ways of
telling stories about everything is
really boils down to the individual
story too whether it's a global scale a
grand scale an intimate you know one man
in in a Hut in the middle of Siberia
um and thank you so much for making
these powerful movies and thank you for
continuing to make these powerful movies
we are in awe of all of our Academy
Award nominees congratulations and thank
you for taking the time to share more
about your films with us today
thank you
thank you so much everyone